hey this is super interesting
last week we did a piece about the 15
minimum wage which uh which i support
you know i've pointed out
there are parts of the country where 15
is uh almost or even more than a
doubling of the current minimum wage
and it may not be the cost of living
adjusted wage but big picture i support
a 15
minimum wage and we talked about how
this new radical wacky
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
tweeted about the minimum wage
something really dumb she tweeted quote
i got my start working at mcdonald's
that job doesn't exist if the minimum
wage is raised to 15 dollars per hour
small business would be crushed by this
arbitrary mandate
and big business would simply automate
away jobs not everything that sounds
good is actually good in practice
and what is fascinating is that now
it just so happens that the company she
mentioned mcdonald's has put out a
statement about this
mcdonald's ceo chris kamzynski
did a fourth quarter earnings call with
investors
on thursday after we had covered this
story
and he said the company is doing just
fine in states that have increased
minimum wages beyond the federal minimum
wage
and we are basically going to be fine we
will do just fine even if minimum wages
continue increasing in a variety of
different states
now kamsinsky wasn't this was a call
with investors
the point here is to reassure investors
it's not
that kemczinski wants higher minimum
wages it's not that mcdonald's is now on
for the fight for 15 or
this is merely a ceo talking to
investors and saying listen
29 states already have higher wages than
the federal minimum
and we're doing just fine and this is
what a four-year analysis by a team of
economists
found for mcdonald's that in applicable
markets where
wages have gone up and as i talked to
you about before
dc is already 15 bucks an hour
mcdonald's is doing fine
california is 13 to 14 an hour
mcdonald's is doing
fine in california uh washington state
is i believe it's 1369.
mcdonald's is doing fine in washington
state and on and on and on
he was just reassuring investors of what
we already
know and um it is true
it is true that when the minimum wage
goes up
the cost of products go up but this is
the
this is such a key finding the study
found
that when the the minimum wage goes up
10 percent
the cost of a of a big mac goes up 1.4
percent
why would it be that if you have a
bigger increase to the wage
the cost of the food only goes up a tiny
bit it's because just as i said last
week
labor is only a fraction of the total
cost
you've got rent for these really
expensive
uh locations that mcdonald's often
operate out of you have the cost of
all of the capital you have the cost of
the food itself
you have insurance you have all these
different things and yes you have labor
and what we again learn
is that labor is only one input and you
can do
wage increases that are meaningful to
the employees
and they have only a minor impact on the
cost of a big of a big mac
now clueless people like lauren bobert
have been able to scam their way into
positions of legislative power
by attaching themselves to really bad
ideas not based in science like
if the minimum wage goes from 8 to 10
then that's 25 that means the food will
all cost
25 percent more and suddenly tons of
people can't afford the food
that's not the reality the reality is
that meaningful minimum wage increases
will have a tiny effect on the food
which yes the
food will be a tiny bit more expensive
but
way more employees now have money with
which they can go to other local
businesses and buy things that's called
demand side
stimulus so uh it nothing of
of what i'm telling you today is new we
did this analysis last week
but hearing it straight from the horse's
mouth the mcdonald's ceo
saying we've done the analysis we have
29 states where minimum wages have gone
up it's fine it's fine and it leads to
this tiny tiny increase to the cost of a
big mac now
i know that there will be the thousand
dollar an hour trolls as i call them but
but david if fifteen dollars is better
than
eight why not pay everybody a hundred
dollars an hour
if more money is good pay everybody
a thousand dollars an hour well no a
thousand dollars an hour is not a
cost of living equilibrium minimum wage
a thousand dollars an hour is not an
industry balanced minimum wage
there is no metric that justifies a
thousand dollars an hour
for people working at mcdonald's it is
not a productivity adjusted wage
it is not an inflation-adjusted wage
that would not make any sense
if you made the minimum wage at
mcdonald's a thousand dollars an hour
uh you would have doctors in many cases
saying i'm better off working at
mcdonald
no nobody's saying that we're talking
about 15
some more expensive places in the
country
would justify you know 18 21 in new york
city whatever
nobody's talking about a thousand that's
called reductio ad absurdum
uh it's a slippery slope it's a red
herring it's a lot of different things
so um again a lot of what i'm saying
here
we said last week but now even the
mcdonald's ceo
when the ceo reassures investors we're
doing fine with higher minimum wages
you know that they're doing fine with
higher minimum wages so we'll keep
talking about this and this is part of a
bigger
focus that i think it's important to
have on workplace issues
democratization of the workplace gig
economy stuff i read some interesting
articles over the weekend
um about different issues facing gig
economy workers and how
uh tech companies that uh are
are sort of exhibiting predatory
behavior or taking advantage of them
we're going to keep talking about this
but as a baseline we have to first build
kind of the base of the pyramid
a lot of the stuff being said by the
right about the minimum wage
is merely disinformation not supported
by left-wing or even many right-wing
economists and we'll have more about it
send me your thoughts i'm on twitter at
deepakman we will take a quick break and
be back after this it's february
it's incredibly february and much to
discuss today